[Music]
we've got pageant history upside-down
Christmas and a suggestive statue take
it away
Tiffany really composed Brad for a story
this girl her name is Mikayla Holmgren
she yeah home hey what up home gran you
my holmgren so you made history I'm
hungry she reads history at the Miss
Minnesota USA pageant by becoming the
very first Miss USA contestant with Down
syndrome oh wait she won she know when
she became uh she's just the very first
USA contestant just tired nobody else
try to be in the Miss USA pageant
damn look I thought thousands of people
always had like oval bodies they have
very similar features I think she still
has like the the features of the face
still but her you she has an hourglass
figure that really changes my ignorant
perspective because I always thought
down syndrome people had the same shape
looking a lot of down syndrome people
that I have met like they all have a
very similar genetically speaking that's
the truth though like this is an outlier
because even their face looks the same
right that's what the Down syndrome
genetic does is it makes your face look
similar and everything is you're shorter
and then you have a shorter life span
that's just all part of dancing I think
I might be on a spectrum though because
I'm assuming because my cousin who has
it he isn't able to speak you know like
I apparently like you can have different
severa T's of County so maybe she has it
like not at a low dose yeah you know
what that just tells me though at
scissors you had really dope parents she
doesn't look like she has down syndrome
here she just looks Asian yeah she's
like a short asian girl
yeah she had really great parents that
were like honey you can do whatever the
[ __ ] you want to do she's a dancer and
like I would never tell my kids you
could do whatever the [ __ ] you want some
people are not supposed to or what huh
some people are not supposed to do
whatever though because what if you have
a [ __ ] garbage as kid and they're
like my goal in life is to own a brothel
and you'd like my mama said that sounds
like that would be your kid no that's
why I gotta tell them you can't do
whatever the [ __ ] you want okay is there
more pictures of her see more pictures
of them I'll show you the two she just
looks like Asian girl than me old is she
she is 22 years old oh cool what made
her want to uh you know and what is it
enroll what do you do college the most
simplest one sign up participate yeah
yeah what made her want to participate
she's participated in a previous pageant
where they have like a pageant for
people with disabilities and so that one
is called Miss amazing and she's
participated that in the past and so for
this time she was just like oh why not
like I want to try it I want to go for
it she wait out another one
so she's won two awards she wants me
what's so funny I don't want to distract
but I just had this image of like so
like okay you know how they try to do
Special Olympics and like all these
different things to help celebrate like
people that you know we're in the past
looked upon as undesirable and and
they're like well let's change the whole
viewpoint of this right but then
sometimes I think what happens is it
makes it worse by making a collection of
everybody together and celebrating that
because it's like the participation
award it's like it's it's kind of like
well you don't want that award because
you know that what kind what it
represents right but when you see them
like let's say one dude only
one leg but he's in a marathon with
people that have normal like two legs
and they didn't he beats the [ __ ] out of
all of them that is like oh [ __ ] that's
inspiring but if you're a first-place
like in the Special Olympics like I
don't know what if they do it just so
that they can also feel like they're
part of this community so for example
like powerlifting with such a small
sport and then once you see another
power lift you're like oh [ __ ] that's
tight like they're more of like you or
more of me out there you know to me I
wonder like it kept the cases when I see
somebody cuz you know we have this like
perception of what Down syndrome is
right yeah and you know she's 22 right
she's pretty million yeah I mean I'm
looking at this girl tonight just dope
right she just looks like a cute little
asian girl even though she's not Asian
and I have which is interesting but now
I'm thinking like what if she goes to
her group of Down syndrome people and
they're like you ain't got Down syndrome
you know so what did she get she gets
bullied the other way around inside you
like trying to be one of us son like a
gang issue okay like where your mom was
going through with like coming from
Mexico and yeah she looks like she's
white exactly so I wonder when I was
bullied by her other downfall
it's like that one movie with Johnny
what's his with a special movie you
remember that movie talking Knoxville
yeah where he pretended that he was
special so you compete in a Special
Olympics and any thought he could beat
everybody but he realized that he's not
that good you know what I mean
yeah that was his there's a short film
where it's they kind of created this
universe where people with special needs
are the normal people and the people
without special needs are are like
treated like [ __ ] it was like the short
film it's not supposed to be it's a it's
a comedy short film but it's pretty
[ __ ] funny because there's this guy I
don't know what he has might be like
cerebral palsy or something but he's in
a wheelchair and this guy who's cuz
they're a normal person has a handicap
tag around him and he's working at a
restaurant and he goes oh he said
something along the lines I'm sorry so
I'm really he goes and the guy who's
like had like a you know like how people
make fun of people who are [ __ ] go
thinking that yeah yeah
so the handicapped dude told the to the
non handicapped dude crazy dude
it's pretty good though I forgot what it
was called but it's really hilarious but
yeah so back to your question bro she
won the spirit of Miss USA award and the
directors award at this particular
pageant that's awesome would you be
happy with those Awards yeah because I
don't get awards period so that's
already awesome cuz you know like it's
like you know a Spartan Race medal it's
a participation medal it is its meaning
will they give everybody that you
completed if you complete it you get a
medal mm-hmm so to me that's a gold star
medal
what if TIFF was like dude I never got
anything and like this matter what I'm
trying to say is what I'm trying to say
is even though it's meaningless I know
that I pretend that it's first place
this first place get a different metal
you get like a coin I think so you get
like us you've got like a Spartan coin
or something it's not is it like a piece
and then the more you win it becomes
something bigger no everyone gets the
piece so you could put it together yeah
but I think if you get the first three
places or five places I think you get a
coin and that coin enters you into like
the main event it's like the what's
their meaning of that they have this
like qualifying main event or something
and and then it wasn't meaningless to me
though I was so proud I finished that it
was so hard meaningful to me I pretend
at its first place but I'm saying for
most people you know what it is
everyone's gaining it if you finish
right that means I was a kid in school
that like I think everyone gets to star
my do you believe in every kid should be
rewarded for everything but for
everything no no not for everything do
you want a lot great what it mean oh no
I just think I don't think I don't like
that whole participation because I think
like it doesn't prepare you for the real
world and that's not the whole like
school everything is supposed to prepare
you for the real world and then now you
you call them innate like this in this
entitlement the sense of entitlement and
once you get to the real world in the
real world its performance or
merit-based promotions right then like
the better you are at something the more
you usually excel and then I think if
you if you used to well there's always
this baseline that I'm supposed to fall
back on that that doesn't exist so I'd
only like to that mentality I think
after a certain age they should stop
that [ __ ] because in the very beginning
when you're dumb as [ __ ]
that's supposed to be okay cuz it's
confidence-building you're so stupid you
don't know cause-and-effect right but
you're a kid you're like 2 years old
and you're getting a [ __ ] star for no
reason you're like well by the time
you're in fifth grade you know you
shouldn't be rewarded like cuz you're
just like I tried real hard where's my
[ __ ] trihard medal yeah and that's
when those kids are coming out straight
out of college with no experience
they're like why am I not getting the
high-paying ass job I did the work to
get the degree you know that's all of us
yeah alright [ __ ] the older generation
for trying to be so nice and changed
themes you know that was a government
initiative though huh that was a
government initiative No Child Left
Behind or is that the same no no I don't
know what it's called right yeah but I
thought it was called it was called
something where you wanted to be more
encouraging so then that's when everyone
got the star and they wanted to do that
and then they started noticing the the
years that it kept they kept
implementing it that kids were coming
out more and more entitled they're like
[ __ ] but they also lied to us too
because if we if we went to school got a
degree we would get a good job in things
like that we would like to both buy from
our parents and from the government that
was true back in the day because
remember when the bachelor degree
actually meant something yeah like a 19
[ __ ] 35 then when I got it nobody gave
a [ __ ] about it anymore it was like it
was already too late man yeah so sad
let's not talk about sad [ __ ] let's go
to the next one all right for the next
story
have you guys been seeing this new trend
with Christmas trees where they are
hanging them upside down oh who is
[ __ ] Santa in the ass right now who's
doing that [ __ ] I'm gonna [ __ ] you up
why is the upside down [ __ ] Christmas
tree everyone's like super fit nowadays
and likes to do handstands everywhere so
it looks interesting you know we don't
know it's not my Christmas a lot of
people are finding it really offensive
because I think the whole upside-down
cross I don't know offensive like to me
it's just like it's not traditional and
that's fine with me but I think it's
also not completely on the other and I
think people like to jump it's true you
know what's ridiculous to me is people
associate Christmas Christmas with a
tree and Santa and all that [ __ ] with
Jesus it's not the same [ __ ] [ __ ] the
Christmas tree all those things that's a
pagan thing that crossed over yeah
worshippers this is annoying because
it's like they literally it's just to be
different yeah I mean like what has is
somebody done with the Christmas tree
[ __ ] like that [ __ ] on fire in the
middle of my house they're doing it in
stores
yeah like departments don't like the
malls and stuff it's mainly that's where
a lot of people are saying is it a
statement this is kind of cool cuz it
looks like a fixture coming down it
would be cool if it wasn't related to
Christmas cuz that's just not how I grew
up so for me it's just so I like
Christmas I copped Christmases to pull
I'm already singing like Christmas
jingles and [ __ ] you know what I mean
call us wanna know tape off I even like
[ __ ] DMX what he bit his little
[ __ ] son ruining Christmas for me
yeah you've ruined Christmas for me ah
[ __ ] [ __ ] DMS yeah I forgot what song
he was doing buddy was I here cause
Santa Claus what you know
[Music]
[Music]
I'm assuming these trees that are upside
down are like the fake trees because
like a real to be super heavy to even
have it to have it the other way yeah
what if it is real though I'll be crazy
I think there's a these are all faking
and they're going for like a thousand
bucks shut the [ __ ] up yeah what I'm
saying like people remember that whole
phase where it was like good
don't say Merry Christmas they say Happy
Holidays it's like I'm not Christians
Merry Christmas [ __ ] to ruin one of my
favorite holidays on earth it's yours
too
yes I love Christmas man I'm getting a
Christmas tree this week we have a
Christmas tree I heard it's your first
one you sad [ __ ] you never bought the
real one he's never had it's so sad dude
do you know they put like gifts under
that tree too and [ __ ] I found out this
yeah I know for some reason I thought
you guys bought one at the old house
that you the bear cave everywhere we
live is a bear cave but that one was
where the name was coined wasn't inner
thinking of when Gina and Shawn moved in
they had a Christmas tree oh my god
Chris this time man
we always had like a Christmas tree that
we put together and then I begged my
[ __ ] parents every year I was like
please please this year I want a real
Christmas tree and we got one and I was
[ __ ] happy as [ __ ] dude I spent so
many like hours designing that
[ __ ] it was so dumb and I begged
him to our street like I grew up in a
pretty dope suburb where a lot of the
homes would would do their [ __ ] house
oh I like that yeah right so then like
the more houses that do it the more
feels dope yeah and then what if you're
the only house that does it then you
look like the dumb one Scrooge
yeah but then like every other two or
three homes did it right so I was like
this here please let's do it so we got
like I wrapped around the board
we got like the the gutter the [ __ ]
uh yeah we got that half way over there
my dad got mad at me and then I had to
finish everything myself but then it was
like a kid doing everything right so I
had two bushes that was wrapped up a
floaty candy cave and half of that [ __ ]
on the roof because I wasn't allowed to
go up there with the [ __ ] thing
dragging from down like the Christmas
light was dragging down and it wrapped
around another bush [ __ ] and it was
wrapped around like a [ __ ] like a
what do you call it that that Japanese
bamboo not a bamboo bonsai like a big
bonsai
dude my dad we tweet when we did
Christmas lines I think we did at one
year and then we just left it up there
for like seven years it was just too
much work to take it down yeah we didn't
take it down our neighbors complain do
it when we when we had a hello white
people in our neighborhood it was so
[ __ ] tight dude white people when
they [ __ ] decorate for Christmas they
do that [ __ ] like it's like a [ __ ]
burning cross for the KKK
maybe that [ __ ] they like their
[ __ ] [ __ ] up it's [ __ ] dude
there's just one white [ __ ] dude
he oh I miss him I hope he didn't pass
away but like about eight or eight or so
years ago he stopped doing but he had
the whole [ __ ] Santa Claus on
the roof thing lit up yeah got him like
going into the [ __ ] chimney to rape
the family of chimneys our place yeah
yeah we had chimney sweep chimneys are
[ __ ] dope oh yeah your house is like
custom-made what's weird Christmas just
feels good dude the music is [ __ ]
dull the air is nice yeah I feel like
when the whole when the whole
neighborhood is like burning their
chimneys to that smoke chimneys in the
South Bay we're beach cities like it
doesn't even make sense but we did yeah
well though they have regulations for
like that [ __ ] too so you can you could
you could only burn a fire on certain
days in your children
no way because of like pollution is [ __ ]
or some suit is to burn that [ __ ] all
the time for fun man yeah [ __ ] was
[ __ ] typos Duraflame logs oh yeah
last story
there was this all-boys school and
Adelaide Australia that erected a statue
and it looks pretty bad so what are you
guys talking about it giving bread to a
boy looks like he's giving the kid a [ __ ]
shot dude yeah they [ __ ] up who who
chiseled this [ __ ] it's all no it's a
stone statue right it's the bread like
like coming out of the robe - orderly
space no it looks like it's coming out
of the road it looks like he's like
giving the kid bread and right when he's
gonna grab me to switch it with his dick
yeah I mean that's right forsooth I got
you you know like that's what it seems
like it's do it whose bread like this
who gives bread like this what about
what about this or like like like like
why is it here I never went to subway
and they handed me a sandwich like if
they were like this right like if the
guy was like yeah he was like kneeling
down and giving it to the kid but he's
not even looking at the kid as if he
like knows he's doing something wrong
then who complained about it though
everyone like the parents like the
parents that saw it they were like why
would you approve of this is another
Engel Davis talking about this looks way
worse
look at us look at the guy's eyes dude
he's like jacking off into his hands it
looks like you guys like a slight smirk
- like what the [ __ ] yeah I bet you
anything it's made by one of those
priests that are actually a pedophile
subconsciously though he doesn't know it
yet
and he's it was actually made by a boy
that was molested personal value have a
kid he goes so deep into the [ __ ]
pedo abyss that I'm like you're now in
the sunken place oh I get what you're
saying it's kind of like artists use art
to kind of like recreate their history
or make it or kind of like heal right
yeah you know it's just a bummer I don't
give a [ __ ] man yeah and he he's
responsible for other statues that they
have at the school and so when they
other statues normal there's like
[ __ ] praying that God has a carrot
out his ass holy [ __ ] yeah this is
brand-new statue and the school was
apologizing because they were like you
know what this design was approved in
two dimensional and so by the time we
saw the three-dimensional sculpture or
statue or so what's the difference on
the two-dimensional of the
three-dimensional apparently in the
two-dimensional it didn't look that bad
what was that as a belly button
you're still weird is that his belly
button look he's looking as balls now
yeah but they saw the physical thing and
they're like oh no why don't they just
like put some sort of like tarp or cover
over so no one sees it it did after all
the complaints from the parents that
looks kind of scary that's scarier worst
is now got a kid peek through the tarp
you're like oh
he's giving them the D it's even worse
because now it's whatever's happening
underneath this you know what I would I
would just destroy it move it
he's not even bad the [ __ ] boom
yeah we're just [ __ ] slice off the
hand and then just deal with the death
because nobody wants to statue at this
point I don't want this near my house
you know it means you know it's funny
maybe all the administrators didn't want
to be the first to say that looks like
you're jacking off to the kids just
argue with like the church about it you
know I mean this like this is completely
in a program don't give a [ __ ] man what
do you mean maybe you're a pervert
create afraid of man don't try to snuff
my flames your perspective okay yeah
they covered it up they're commissioning
the same dude to fix it
last time how can I fix it okay just be
the bread man it's not my fault are you
guys the perfect you know white guy what
a hell no big that big what the [ __ ] man
this tweet here it says I'm not sure
what's more symbolic the fact that a
Catholic college put up a statue
inverted ly highlighting sexual abuse of
young boys or the fact that they've
covered it up oh that's deep
[Music]